[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Adam Suhail the same postdoctoral
associate at the South Asian Studies
counsel at the Macmillan Center he is
trained as a social anthropologist and
his work broadly pertains to issues in
the Anthropology of politics and the
politics of knowledge production his
research interests are situated at the
intersection of the Anthropology of
violence state theory and urban
anthropology and his work has been
published in a number of publications
today we'll talk with Professor Suhail
about his research on gang violence in
Pakistan
welcome professor Suhail hi Marilyn
thank you for having me here so let's
begin with an overview of your work tell
us about it
well Marilyn I work on cities I work on
cities and the processes that produce
conflicts as well as cooperations in the
city and my work ties all of these
processes to desiring bodies right I
look at the ways in which these diverse
and multi scalar processes of desiring
sometimes converge at other times
diverge and sometimes the residue of
these processes is violence and in order
to study this I went to my hometown my
field site is where I grew up which is
the city of Karachi which has been going
through a number of conflicts but as
well as a number of these beautiful
coming together of people in times of
crises and so it became an apt place to
study these processes okay and what led
you to study gang violence specifically
well I studied gang violence precisely
because of this one curious fact that
everybody all antagonistic forces people
who absolutely hate each other's got
people who are on completely opposite
sides of the spectrum
somehow agree that gangs are this this
socially pathological formation in the
city and that something must be done
about it now they verily disagree they
vehemently disagree on what that
intervention should be but they do think
that it is something worth intervening
in and for me that became that consensus
that grand consensus became a starting
point how come people who absolutely
despise each other who absolutely
disagree with each other's political
social worldviews agree on this one fact
that is weird that is difficult to find
in this world and that became the
starting point for my for my inquiry now
as I said I studied desire so one of the
main questions for me was well how are
these desires converging on the around
this one object called the gang or or
this one space called the gangland and
and so gang violence became one of the
best ways to study the ways in which
political consensus might be achieved
around an object seen as a site of a
problem okay so how did you do the
research well in order to study gangs
gangs are notoriously hard to study
exactly simply because if one goes out
to study a gang one wants people to be
doing gangly things right that is not
what they do
99% of the time okay 99% of the time
spoiler alert there's just regular human
beings doing regular human being things
now the epistemology on gangs
specifically in the US where it is very
very well studied a little bit too well
studied which is to say that the gang
becomes an object of so many desires
right well
here it appears as if the gang only
appears as a criminological entity as an
entity that needs to be dealt with on
the criminal logical level and I
absolutely disagree with that there is a
century of research a whole century of
social scientific research on gangs and
that is what I had to challenge so I
took two routes the first one was I went
and lived with them so I did two years
of ethnographic fieldwork in this place
called Lyari in Karachi which became
identified as the gangland as sort of a
frontier where the red of the Pakistani
state does not exist well it wasn't
quite true but I had to go and find out
how it was not true and how political
order how life two million people lived
there so how life went on right in this
no-go zone and so I did ethnography but
then in order to actually really
contextualize the activities that I saw
the kinds of ways in which gangs were
mediating and becoming really project
managers for processes that were
transnational national as well as
informal and illicit I'm not denying the
illicit part of their activities well in
order to put them in context I had to go
to London England where exists a huge
body of colonial archives and I wanted
to look at the people of this region
that specific population that specific
area and how it has been sort of
characterized and how did it become what
it is today across centuries and I found
some astounding data there that sort of
helped me figure out what was actually
going on in theory okay so tell us about
the astounding data well one of the
issues is that we think that gangs are a
recent phenomena and urban phenomena but
actually what are gangsters today were
at one time traders Karachi is a port
city and the Indian Ocean trade
in across the 18th century was one of
the most lucrative zones of exchange in
the world
it was extremely profitable and the the
population that we identify with gangs
in Karachi today were at the time
seafarers and sailors now as the
colonial regime comes in at the Imperial
geography expands itself and envelops
Karachi people who were just
transporters before become smugglers
right and so and then the ethnic group
that is identified with this locality
which is the Baloch the British
identified them as the criminal tribes
which is just an index of the fact that
these were people who were not willing
to lay down quietly and so there were
political dissidents and so in the
Imperial geography there is countless
instances where political resistance is
criminalized this looked eerily like
interwar Chicago and to tell the story
of Lyari one has to go to Chicago also
where in the interwar period really
influential social scientists embarking
on an enterprise at the University of
Chicago that sort of really built the
American social sciences in many many
ways both methodologically and
epistemologically well these guys were
looking at two waves of migration one of
african-americans escaping Jim Crow
South and ethnic whites escaping
war-torn and sort of unstable Europe
mostly from Eastern Europe and they were
looking at these migrant communities
that were thrust into sort of these
these shanty towns in this quickly
industrializing Chicago right and they
were saying let's go study them these
other people right and there was an
emergent social form within those groups
as well
that we're looking to sometimes get
access to jobs right one of the ways in
which gangs operated was they were they
got you access to jobs and hence their
association betrayed unions in this
country with labor unions and they did
community protection bands of young men
would get together and protect their
communities in a highly charged
atmosphere and extremely violent
post-war America we're sort of we don't
have any sense of like the PTSD a very
good sense of exactly what went on after
World War one and these boys who were
coming back bringing violent urges and
traumas with them so the 1920 is a Al
Capone sort of we associate these things
right well these guys all sort of
well-meaning social scientists went into
these slums of Chicago these looking at
these these migrant communities and said
hey they have this violent social form
we'll name it the gang and that really
codified what the gang is so when I went
to the archive to put a longer to cut a
long story short I looked at both the
way the word gang the became an
analytical category by eliding it's a
racialized construction by alighting is
classed construction it has a category
of difference and pathology by
definition rather than the contingent
circumstances of interwar Chicago so the
career of the category of the gang as
well as the career of these people the
genealogy the history of these people
across centuries who are now identified
as a gang Simkin though these so these
two sort of threads one from Chicago and
the other from England merged and
constructed the space that is not
presenting itself as the problem of the
gangland in contemporary Pakistan I say
okay so when you say contemporary what
is the time that you are studying well
that's actually an excellent question
because time is not linear in many of
these if you really look at these
thanks closely it contracts and expands
and it fractures and it comes together
so it's it's a difficult thing to
pinpoint but everybody again grand
consensus everybody in Pakistan was
absolutely adamant that at some point in
the late 90s this peaceful working class
zone of old city Karachi where people
just sang and danced and sort of reveled
in their poverty those good old people
and sort of like ethnic racial religious
harmony which is true right centuries of
it right working people solidarity
leftist progressive politics all of this
is true to an extent somehow out of the
blue somewhere at the end of the of the
ninth of the 1990s suddenly becomes a
violent gangland okay and so sort of
that suddenness is precisely what this
three century of research actually tries
to question so it was it really that
sudden and so the rise of the gangs
actually in this temporality coincides
firstly with the coming of a military
dictatorship a us-backed military
dictatorship in Pakistan okay which
abetted this war on terror temporality
and and so Karachi being the financial
and really sort of the economic hub of
Pakistan the biggest city in in the
country and one of the biggest cities in
the world really how does one stabilize
order in a place where one has
destabilized any form of democratic
political process well one does throat
so through strong men through enabling
strong men and so an easy answer would
be and not an incorrect answer would be
that the rise of the gangs coincided
with the rise of a bigger gang in
Pakistan which what the Pakistani army
taking over at the date okay so my next
question would be of course why did the
military allow the gangs to persist in
that area especially since it was you
know the financial
centre of the country well so this is
the this is a part of gang research that
we don't actually sort of talk about too
much which is exactly what does it mean
for a city to be the financial center of
a country right and well economists good
ones and anthropology social scientists
have generally been sort of have now
converged on to the fact that there is a
very strong relationship between
informal illicit dark shadow economies
and what we know as the economy right
the national economy or the city's
economy and actually what we realize is
that activity and exchange in this
sphere this this informal sphere is
infrastructural to many of the
activities that are going on in the
formal sphere in places such as the post
colony the post colonial States the this
relationship is far more entangled it's
far more visible visibly entangled so
right now we're going through the whole
Ukraine controversy here well that
appears as a shock to people right
Russia Gate may appear as a shock to
people but this is the way politics has
happened in most of the world for most
of time and so that process becomes bare
when one looks at gang activity so when
you say why would they allow I would say
why would there not because gang
activities these gangs are embroiled in
as I said 300 years of connections the
Baloch people are spread the Baloch
people and their their business partners
and their and their friends and their
cooperative groups are spread out
throughout Pakistan Afghanistan Iran the
Persian Gulf the Gulf states Saudi
Arabia East Africa right the bullish
people are not racially uniform so in
Karachi there is a fro Baloch people as
well as
Pashtun Baloch people they present as
different but they all call themselves
polish and they all accept each other
the way balázs what do you mean by that
that's a very good question it's
difficult to say the Baloch in Pakistan
become an ethnic group but and they are
a peripatetic people with a very robust
oral history of themselves but because
they are spread out across these oceanic
and terrestrial boundaries across these
different states always at the margins
always the seafarers and the caravan
drivers and traders and sailors it is
they become different people they accept
different people they are accepted into
different socialities very easily
they're easy to get along and they keep
those ties my gangs were utilizing those
networks to run their in formal and
informal and illicit economies and that
is how they were buttressing a city that
was facing and is still facing intense
social ecological political crises right
it is a city where resources are being
channeled and distributed in such a way
that it's producing huge huge swaths of
marginalized populations that don't have
access to housing that don't have access
to water drinking water is a is
vanishing in Karachi as in most of South
Asia climate change is happening and so
how do you then keep the city running
well you draw in these centuries of
informal networks and have this the
special population the balázs people who
become off the place wherever they are
so a gangster in India for instance
being hunted by the police may have a
cousin who's a migrant worker in Bahrain
who's working for the Bahraini police
stomping down the Arab Spring for the
Bahraini state and so producing order in
a very different capacity there as the
police the Omani army the army of oman
is largely Baloch and has historically
been that there's Baloch communities
throughout Kenya and Tanzania and sort
of Zanzibar Iran again they have a
separatist movement there there
marginalized and sort of brutalized
there as well as well as in Pakistan and
so the Baloch are many things but in
being many things they can draw on those
many resources and connections okay
let's get back to the violence of the
gang sure sure
so you've described how the gangs help
to really create political order right
but there's also violence involved and
and I'm curious to know how the media
looks upon the violence that's that's an
excellent excellent question and the
media has played a role in producing
Lyari
as a gangland and producing the gang as
as this specter of arbitrary
unreasonable pathological violence the
media has sort of played a role by and
large in in flattening many of the
nuances of gang activity in Leary so for
instance what you would find if you
stumbled into a li re in 2009 just
before the the gang violence truly sort
of reached its epic epic proportions and
and became like this something that was
threatening the rate of the Pakistani
state or so we heard in 2009 you stumble
into a re and you'll find that these
gangs were involved in in processes by
which they were claiming funds from
USAID to promote women's education in in
in Li re because they said and mostly
rightly so that in the age of Islamic
terrorism or Buddhist perception of
Islamic terrorism the Baloch were a
Muslim community that have practiced and
indifference to difference they are
extremely secular in their social
outlook and they're Pro women's
education so give us the development
money give us the DFID money
and we will promote girls education in
this part of Lyari
and they were fairly successful in doing
that so those are the kinds of processes
you will see there right so in the first
phase when when when the gangs are sort
of stabilizing political order these are
the kinds of activities that are taking
part in there they're running they're
inaugurating cultural shows and funding
plays and sort of acts of charity I mean
so there is a dichotomy there though
they're doing all of this wonderful
thing but absolutely then there's also
the violence so how does that come into
play well that's that's a thing in the
process of the stabilization this is
something I write about in the book
which sort of I'm working on which is
that in the process we have to take this
as a temporal process right in the first
phase they are stabilizing order but
then at some point the gangs figure out
that why are we doing this on behalf of
people sitting in the Capitol the
political elite of the city we're the
ones who are doing all this stuff right
so so rather than staying in this
liminal position as instruments of order
they try to become party to order itself
so around 2009/2010 these gangsters they
decide to join politics they they make
these overtures to political formations
that's not acceptable right because that
is not what maintains order in the city
the key role is precisely that they they
stay on this border between formal and
informal state and society law in outlaw
right that's what their function is in
maintaining order if they drop to either
side completely they lose that position
they can't broker order and so what
they're trying to do in their ambitions
their desire to become legitimate is
bucking this order right they're
destabilizing it and so then follows an
intense period this is the second phase
where not only are they fighting amongst
themselves to become this order but also
the political
late the Pakistani government which by
this time the the military has been
humiliatingly driven out of power
through a People's Democratic Movement
in 2007 and 2008 well by this time
nobody wants them around because they
have all these ambitions and so in the
second phase
there's intra gang violence but also
inter-gang violence but also the gangs
are becoming too much for the state to
handle they're not playing their part as
instruments anymore and so they must be
culled and so there is in 2013 a
military operation and so the military
that was humiliatingly driven out of
power in 2007 can now in 2013 come back
and say look your city is going to the
dogs we're coming in and we're saving
you right and so those who were their
erstwhile partners in the in the phase
between 99 and and 2008 now they're
coming onto the streets of the city a
good excuse to come onto the streets of
the city and they kill young men young
Baloch men from Li re indiscriminately
they kill them they render them
disappear see though they disappear them
or they put them in these draconian
anti-terror courts where due process is
abrogated really that were sort of
instituted in Pakistan beginning to 2014
and and did they take care of the
problem but once they're there they've
never left so now the the Pakistani army
has a permanent presence of policing
presence on the streets of the city so
that is the situation today and there is
no longer any gangland violence but
there probably is military violence well
yes a bit of both the military works in
in very different ways in in diverse
ways it's it's not it's a huge
enterprise and so it it articulates its
power in in various different ways it
has it commands a lot of different kinds
of activities so it doesn't need to
always resort to overt violence but we
know that there's different kinds of
violence the gangs yes they're no longer
there as such and sort of Lyari became
after the gangs this this poaching
ground or I don't know I don't want to
call it a poaching ground but a way in
which lots of human rights and
educational sort of all these different
kinds of NGOs and entrepreneurial groups
could swoop in onto the remnants of what
the gangs left behind the rubble after
the gang war and sort of really
appropriate cheap labor devalued labor
of the people of Lyari
and say oh look you're from the gangland
nobody else will give you a job but look
out of the kindness of out of the
kindness of my heart why don't you work
as an entrepreneur for my factory not in
the factory but stay at your home build
whatever I need you to build and I'll
give you and I'll buy it from you for 50
cents on the dollar you know like those
are the kinds of things that are
happening in the area it's really tragic
that this is the cost of peace pure
exploitation but the gangs of course
these formations don't completely die
and so last January a really sort of
well respected political figure in
Karachi who lived in a completely
different part of town and sort of
affiliated in with a very different kind
of politics he was his car was just
entering his driveway and these two
young men approached
on a motorbike and right in front of his
his gate they shot him point-blank and
they killed him this had nothing to do
with Larry but when and the state didn't
want to really pursue the case they were
sort of dragging their feet and
everything eventually when they were
forced through social media through sort
of political pressure by the victim's
family they came out and they said oh
these were hired killers who are
affiliated with the Larry gang war by
this time the gangs are completely
decimated right and so what you have are
these remnants who have had a career
in some kind of violence who are now
sort of these free radicals floating
around in the city trying to figure out
their place there and so gang violence
has disappeared but violence in the city
these are people of the city desiring
bodies with their own aims with their
own trajectories and their tools and
their trades and their practices so the
activist was targeted for his activism
or for another reason he was actually a
politician from from a major political
party and so after the military cleaned
up the gangs it turned its eyes onto
other sources of disorder in the city
and and this is sort of outside the
purview of my own work and other people
have done great research on this they
looked to this one political formation
that had been quite dominant in the city
for the past 30 40 years and then they
turned to them and then they decimated
that political formation which was an
extremely complex often extremely
violent but often extremely popular
political formation in the city okay and
so yeah and so what you see in Pakistan
is at this moment a fracturing of
political opposition through various
processes
this was one of them peculiar to the
city of Karachi okay I know you are
continuing this work with a book do you
want to briefly tell us about it yes my
book I've just recently sort of settled
on a title which again may change a lot
of people get to have a say in it
including my lovely wife but it's called
The Machine's of violent desire and it's
pretty self-evident why I would that but
also looking at gangs as the
articulation of a weight of desires
right both sort of the Pakistani state
which I've been talking about but also
they were partaking in polio vaccination
campaigns that were funded by the w-h-o
sitting in Geneva trying to eradicate
polio of the face of the earth right
these guys were instrumental in
affecting that in Karachi so so that
desire to sort of for public health for
instance right that desire for ordering
the city for for security in the city
for people to have access to basic
necessities in a city that's really
facing the brink of of this this climate
induced crisis climate change induced
crisis so the gang becoming an
articulation point for these various
processes of desiring that's what the
book is exploring okay well we will look
forward to hearing more about that thank
you so much for being here Thank You
Marilyn wonderful conversation for more
information about Professor Suhail and
his research please visit our website at
macmillan report yelled at edu be sure
to join us again for another episode of
the Macmillan report made possible
through funding from the Whitney and
Betty Macmillan Center for International
and area studies at Yale
[Music]
you